welcome
dear audience here at the berlinand
science week to the ERF future Talk
Fascination of marine research Europe's
mission to protect the fair because
several and waters and if you know
marine research I think it's cool that's why
I'm here I have no idea
what EFR is supposed to be then I can  They
calm down they will go home after these 90
minutes as experts or experts
my name is fritz habekus
i am an editor at die zeit and
science writer and your moderator for
the afternoon
and to get in the mood for the topic
we have prepared a short trailer
[music]
like  we want to live digitally
how do we stay healthy for as long as possible
[music]
how can the environment be protected
and how does the Europe of tomorrow look like?
Questions like these concern
us all and researchers
throughout Europe
work together on solutions and answers to
the European  Research space EFR for short
ensures the right
framework conditions and necessary
research freedoms
in the Ehefa-future talks give
researching insights into your field
and answers to your questions in direct exchange with
the audience
in our episodes we go
on a journey of discovery together with you and
find out what is happening in Europe  research is currently being
carried out and what innovations await us
have fun
who paid attention knows it is the
European research area that we
want to talk about above all else
we want to talk about the ocean and
if some of you have just been to the
event of the German
Marine Research Alliance
then you know that we
have to talk about the ocean or the sea if we want to
talk about the climate about the climate crisis
want to talk about the biodiversity crisis want to talk about the biodiversity crisis
without the
ocean is not the largest ecosystem
on the planet at all one in ten
people is directly dependent on  the protein from
fish from more than half of the
world's population live on coasts the sea
is a source of raw materials
for building materials but also for rest and
relaxation you
probably know this because most of
you probably
go to the sea on vacation from time to time but that  The sea is
also under threat I once looked up a few
headlines from the past few weeks
that you connect when you
click through the science pages on the Internet. There
is so much plastic in the sea that a
single blue whale could eat up to 10
million pieces of plastic a day.
Annually around 740,000  kilometers
long and pushing around 14 billion
bait hooks lost in the sea since the
1950s, the top
two kilometers of the sea are warming more
than twice as fast today as they did in the
1960s the Arctic Ocean
represents a caustic shift and
yesterday's news in  The climate in Europe is warming up
more than twice as
fast as the global average, which does
n't really put us in a good mood, but
we have a whole series of very, very
exciting guests who are
dealing with what can be done about it and
what answer research can give
us  actually have very, very
many different or three very
different perspectives
people here who are doing research on this in the ERA in the European
Research Area
and again to explain this term
a bit
because it is a bit cloudy the
European Research Area is something
like the internal market for  science
and that's about
finding solutions deepening cooperation
finding a solution for a green
transformation, and not just
on the scientific level, but also
in exchange with citizens with the
public this is an example
of how this can succeed we have
experts
who  doing this has been new for a long time
so the ERA is a rather old idea
or it has been new for a very long time is
the mission-oriented approach that
started in Europe last year
the EU proclaimed five missions
one of them is just several and
waters by 2030  to protect and
restore I have just
outlined a bit what kind of problems there are that
sounds like a very
ambitious goal we also want to
talk about how realistic it is
to set such a goal and then
pursue it but first I would like to
introduce you and yourselves  my three
guests a first guest is director of the
German Institute of development and
sustainability and professor for
global sustainable development at the
University of Bonn she was previously a professor of
social sciences in the Marientropen
at the University of Bremen has worked in Southeast and
Central Asia and East and West Africa
that sounds like  After a
pretty good job, I have to say
she is a specialist in ocean
governance, so all these rules and
laws and institutions and
political measures that have to do with the ocean,
she advises the
federal government, the United Nations,
the European Union and she says
Europe is responsible for the  World is an absolute
exception in that Europe is the only
region in the world that has something like a
divided science science area
warmly welcome to the Katharina thank you
very much hello
how can you you are a sociologist and
marine researcher that fits at first
glance it doesn’t sound like it would
fit together you
explain how your everyday life looks like what kind of
questions you are dealing with
so i am a sociologist of knowledge and
development sociologist and i have been
working for a little over seven
years now also to the sea i initially
worked to terrestrial ecosystems especially in the area
of ​​agriculture  and to ask about
land and water management that was always
my one area the other
area I deal with questions
of scientific systems
which role knowledge different
types of knowledge can and should play in
development processes in social processes of
change
and
I work towards more  once to ask about
marine governance, she already tells me about the
control system at multilateral
level and also at European level,
just today we had a
workshop on the impact of a
European
partnership greements in on West Africa,
i.e. the impact, so to speak,
transregional impact of
EU policies on the  the
small-scale fishery in parts of
West Africa
and the other side, so to speak, to the sea
is also in a joint project in
GEOMAR of other colleagues but joint
project it's about marine
carbon measurement that
's a global scientific system
and at the same time it's not
global but we collect or  In the
sense of marine sciences, we collect
more CO2 measurements, so to speak, and that
is fed into
databases from very
different national contexts,
and that is always accompanied by
major differences depending on
how the various
scientific systems are equipped,
and that interests us  So how does
the equipment of
different scientific systems affect
our human knowledge in relation
to marine CO2 measurements and what does
that mean for climate policy
negotiations if we
only know parts of the entire
situation but CO2 is CO2
no matter what part of the world it is
Why are there problems in the
translation of the data
because we are now specifically in the Marian area,
we are collecting the data from a few and
above all largely nationally
organized scientific systems,
so I said earlier in
the global scientific system, that's
wrong, we don't have a global
scientific system, we have  we have a
great many
scientific systems with dramatically different equipment spread across the globe
and
a
number of scientific systems are involved in the marien co2 measurement, but of
course by far not 198
and that in turn is very
different in each case it also means in
the in  the appointment of agents, so to speak, in
the formulation of what is
actually being researched along with which
standards, with which methods, with
which technical support
and means,
since
certain regions of the world basically
also make specifications here,
namely often the well-equipped
generally the well-equipped
science systems  of the North,
but that means on the global level of
political
negotiation that we as a
world society do not
have a common ability to speak, we also do
not have a common ability to act
in the contexts when data is fed into the databases, so to speak,
from a few
scientific systems
and yes, then the
analyzes are also from a few
scientific systems
and then that we keep demanding at
international level
from many, many other countries
that they believe almost blindly
what the science
of the North will say, in a somewhat
simplified way, from the science
of the North and there
then we actually come up against
our limits on uneven ground and that is highly problematic, especially in
areas that in all global
challenges where it is also very clear that
we as the world community have to
deal with them, because then there is
an incredible potential for division,
even now against the geopolitical
background like the one in  that we are
in and the
European research area is actually
a really noteworthy exception to
make that concrete. I
now have that from a guest contribution
that you wrote that
the budget of Germany that
goes into research  are about three
percent while in a comparison of
Indonesia it is always 0.28 percent in the eight largest
economy on earth
so it is science
in the end also a question of power that is
the systems are very
very differently equipped
exactly and that is precisely in Indonesia
i think that they are 16 largest
economy in the world it is a g20 country
and that is of course a political
decision whether to invest in the
generation of the future by
investing accordingly in education and research systems or
not and we have others
Situations in general it's like that,
for example in sub-Saharan Africa I just
checked the figures again, 0.4 percent of
research expenditure
falls and of course these are
situations in which the few
scientists from these under-
equipped scientific systems
still work in international
cooperation  come together and shape agents with
scientists here from the German
or other European contexts are
also in a weaker
situation and, above all,
are in great demand yes, we do
compete with each other when
we sometimes try to get together with our
African or Asian partners
because then there are not
that many we'll continue with
the round of introductions the man
who is
looking over your shoulder with an octopus
is a physical oceanographer he is
researching at the GEOMAR Helmholtz Center
for Ocean Research in Kiel like the ocean
Circulation of mass and heat
works and works, among other things,
on developing new techniques for
observing the sea, for example as part of
the eurosie project, which
is funded by the EU with partners from 14
countries. He says that we
talk to each other in European research
and do science together  is
an ancient thought alone no
country could meaningfully explore the oceans
nice that you are here Johannes
Carsten
when I
hear oceanographers then I always think
that is a great job that
definitely swims with sharks and snorkels with
Wahlen and hears humpback whales
doing oceanographers  she actually does that so it
's a great job
but that's exactly what I don't do before
Elections sometimes when I
put the microphone in the water because I
actually want to hear something else, for
example sound propagation to
get my measuring devices back on deck
so I studied physics and  I
then specialized in
physical oceanography, which means
it's mainly about currents,
temperatures, salinity, dense energy
in the ocean in general and how it
moves and clearly the energy is what
we all feel and exactly ocean that
's all the processes in the ocean
So it's biology
as well as chemistry
are somehow always connected with this
physical and with energy
and that's actually something
I really appreciate about my job,
that although I'm a physics professor
I still work with a lot of other
disciplines  can and
must
and my passion is that i
set off typically once a year
i'm
on the road with the research ship and there are certain
measurement strategies that we've thought about that
attack the same topics one
topic is of course the climate, which is also
central here again and again  Space is standing, that
means we have had
series for a relatively long time now where we
look at how changes in the ocean
become visible. The ocean is
a medium that is very variable
everywhere and if you
want to see real changes then you have to
measure for quite a long time  and
on the other hand, that is also
something that an individual cannot somehow figure
out anyway, nor
can a country solve it alone,
but that is why it is very, very
important that you work in a
European research area and then in the
end too  in the global research area
comes together can act together
so there is a podium where we
can interact with each other and I
think we are in a
very good position in Europe and to now
briefly go into this uc project
this is a project where  we
carry out observations, but
in particular also take these observations
in order to then bring them to the women with the
corresponding users of observations
or products of observation that are
users
are, for example, there is a fish farm
somewhere, let's say off Norway, these
are potential users of the ocean
Information that wants to know there is
now a heat anomaly on my
fish farm and I had to move it 50 km
further so that
I can avoid it. To
get such information from the ocean,
a chain of processes is
necessary that is first the observation
but then  you just need machinery
that we ultimately also saw here,
i.e. computer programs computers
that integrate the whole thing is a
vision that we all have that we
have such a digital twin of the oceans
so that we have the ocean as a digital twin there
for relevant questions all the time
we are
fed with information from the
ocean and where we
can pull out specific information in order to be able to process it for a problem
such as a fish farm, for example,
and that makes us do a
small test in quotation marks
in this July project in the more
diverse groups there
bring together and some exemplary
activities such as fish farming but also such as
CO2 absorption in the ocean and
then deriving,
for example,
general economic zones how much CO2
with my general economic zone
also economic zone I think you have to
put it differently, a bit more that
every country around  if it
then borders on the sea and that's
about 200 miles, about almost
500, 350, 380 km, these zones extend
out, so a large piece that still
belongs to the individual countries if
you look at a map of the world
where these general economic zones are  are
drawn because my
something like 40 percent remains the ocean
over which there is not a general
economic zone, so these
general economic zones are already
significant make countries very very large
in some cases and then you can
ask yourself questions like how much CO2
my general economic zone
might absorb  Can I anchor that in my
national action plan, i.e. in
my er plan for my
or not?
a question that we are also
tackling with this puresy project as a European group and you
also take care of the questions of how to incorporate
this type of research into the
public is one thing because
they have talked about the products before
and is an example of
fish farms but there are probably
others that shipping probably
also wants to know where are where
can I send my ships long
or or port cities are very
interested in this type of  in terms of
research exactly exactly so in fact
Europe is like that I think I've
actually followed it myself over the
last 20 years or so where
in Europe many institutions or
groups have been set up that
act as a whole European for
weather forecasting there's something like
that anyway  is called the
european center for medium-term
weather forecasts,
all the
national weather centers grab their
information and then make
the weather forecast for Germany, for example, they
need
the whole world, of course, and they take it
from this, and the same thing
also applies to an ocean there  So what is the
Siemens Kopernikus Marine
environmental monitoring service called, it
doesn't matter, it's definitely a huge apparatus
that's also distributed across different
European countries but acts together
and they make, for example, models that
are specially designed for shipping, for example for route optimization, and that
's just it  the good thing is that it is their job,
that means they have also
established mechanisms with which you can communicate with
these stakeholders
because that is exactly the
huge problem as well as I myself as a
scientist will not be able to
communicate directly with the stakeholders anyway we can now
communicate here but in a different way
way than it is necessary if
I now bring a product like a a
heat anomaly for the fish Pharma ashore
yes exactly that you can
do well with subordinate forms of dialogue
I would like to
bring Katrin knickmeyer in the third guest because  their
specialty is actually how do
you communicate with the public
and how do I bring this kind of
knowledge to the general
public and the general
public they deal with
are children and young people
above all they have at the at the
Christian Albrechts University in  Kiel,
the children and students at the University
have been responsible for over 15 years and have
previously
worked as polar researchers and
researched plankton in the oceans
and are from the
founding directors of the Kiel
research workshop and at the
Leibniz Institute for
Science and Mathematics Education
in citizen science you are leading
the plastic pirates project that
is in the process of being rolled out in quite a
number of other european
countries and
yeah what really interests me is
how why have you
turned to the question of how to get this kind of
knowledge that you collect and then often
which, one has to say, is often
published and then read by a very,
very small number of people at
all, and it is
often not that easy to
understand what was actually
researched on, why, why did you
make this shift towards  the question of
how to communicate, well, I'll
start first, I've been in the business for a long time,
so my first
research trip was in 1982,
40 years ago, on the old Meteor in the
Arctic, because I was only doing
polar research with plankton
and that was basic research
I was the only woman with 72 men on
board that fortunately changed
and
then Wednesday I stayed with it
exactly then Meteor Polarstern the new
Meteor and so on then on a
north-east passage a lot there in the
research ships and later  I
then had three children was also in
South America in Chile I also did
research on plankton and with the children
it was more difficult with
research back then I have to say that today
it is better I would say for the
following generation to accommodate the togetherness
with the children  It's
difficult then to go on research trips
that last ten weeks or things like that,
so I then
switched to working with children and
young people and
first did courses on beaches, then
back to the university and there, in
the school programs, I sort of came
up with things like  you
can inspire children and young people the
children's university was a great success and
the research workshop is a
facility where school classes can in
non-corona years we have 150
school classes who complete day programs there,
but we also have
projects such as the plastic pirates or a
biodiversity project on various
topics where  Pupils
can also do some research in the afternoon
European project
that is, so to speak, a project that we
started several ocean and ocean
before that we worked with Chile
because I was there too Chilean beaches
German beaches children and young people
blocked exchanged ideas, so to speak
what does the garbage look like
where does it come from what's going
on in Germany and then we in
Germany we were asked by the BMBF to
come up with a project for the youth project science they have several and ocean what
works for all of Germany and that
doesn't work with the  beaches
so we came up with the rivers
and the rivers were just a great
topic so plastic unfortunately also a great
topic meanwhile everyone knows how
it looks everywhere and even if you go to rivers or tendons or even travel through the world  That's how the
plastic pirates came about and
it was really a great success
that Munich school classes
were able to do ocean research by taking part in such projects on the Isar
or the Rhine or something like that
and also really
researching something were real researchers and
that's our
citizen science city this
science  Project the plastic pirates and there
are rivers that don't stop at the
German border the Danube does have its
source in the Black Forest but it
flows through twelve countries to the
Black Sea and then it
worked out that it's spreading
now there are
a few countries that are now in the fall  on
sampling I didn't even know that the
Danube originates in the Black Forest, you have to
learn a
lot yourself when you deal with things,
but we also have a
watershed in Germany and
part of it also drains the North Sea and Baltic
Sea  Doesn't end at our
German border, the Rhine doesn't
just end there, so now Holland is
there too, and Lithuania is there, Hungary is
now there, Austria is there too, and so we hope
that we'll work our way through Europe and
the rivers connect the countries, the
seas, actually, the people  because
there are no limits you
just said then the
schoolgirls from Munich ocean research
were really scientists, that means the results
were also published or
processed in some way that the
research they could use we are
very proud of that we  have
various publications, but we
also have publications in well-known specialist
journals because mental
solution or science of the total
environment are now also included in such
journals  I would
also like to say something about
enforcing that, because it is exactly
how important it is, I would
just open the circle a bit,
so how important is it then to
work together on a European level in the fields that you are dealing with,
so here it sounded very clear  and
quite clearly, because rivers cross
national borders, waters do
not stop at
national borders, but how important
is this European this European cooperation for the research you do,
so European cooperation is
very important, and I just
said that  Europe, I would like to
say that again because I
think it is really worth mentioning. Europe is
the only regional organization that is
building and expanding this scientific area substantially through investments in science and thus also this scientific area as a jointly divided scientific area
and thus makes a contribution
for a European identity,
what happened there is not only
the promotion of science itself,
but that science and
science policy are used as an
instrument for other
political goals and especially the construction
of a European identity if you
take that to a higher level and
remember that you just said 40 percent
of the ocean is outside the
exclusive zone, which means they
are not regulated,
but they are not international
regulated and always require
exchange at multilateral level,
i.e. at UN level,
and if so  we now have a
multilateral DFG, so to speak, to put it simply, the
German
Research Foundation or Horizon
2020 and so on, but also a European
research program
at world level or at
multilateral level, a
funding organization that says we have
understood that science funding
is more than just science funding
for me it is also
scientific diplomacy, is it
a diplomatic act and
an instrument that develops a leverage effect
in order to shape the future and to create
a common identity and also an
identification with these global
challenges, which is also an issue for you,
that would of course be a
we don't have any more crazy things to win, but
we don't have approaches for NES because
you have a forum and so on, but they
are very, very underfinanced, so it
's really worth mentioning that Europe
is doing this and actually the only one,
so at a level worth mentioning, the
only regional organization is that
does
because to put it concretely at
Eurocity, for example, with 14 with
countries from 14 partners from 14 countries you
can
simply agree on common goals
and do you always want the
same thing and do you want Norwegian
salmon farmer or  the same as an
Italian coastal country,
in principle, yes, in principle, it's
about creating this chain in the
project, that is, the
chaining of some problem, it
can be a Norwegian problem, but it can
just as well be an Estonian one
or I don't know what kind  be a problem
and then you want to come to the
corresponding solutions, that means then
to this product that
somehow addresses these problems in
some way, you also want to come and that
means that it is such a
generic in itself is such a yes always the
that in  The principle is always the same
procedure, which of course is then
adapted depending on the problem, so
of course it’s different if I’m a fish farm
consultant than if I’m somehow
doing route optimiser or climate research, but in principle we also call this
the ocean
observation-oping value chain, i.e.
the chain of effects of the  Ocean observation that
means we start a problem, then
we formulate the problem,
carry out our observations
or bring the observation together and make
one against a product
that we then in turn
market and
that's actually what we're
also tackling in this project and that's just
a  great project precisely for the fact
that this has to be done from different
files within Europe
because you can't
do it all alone.
Observations are very expensive and that's
why it's also very, very important
that you even share them with each other
so that everyone can share their
economic chains  can therefore generate
data
sharing information sharing practice sharing
Best Practices very very big topic in
this project with the main topic will
yes I might just add it briefly
because you had already emphasized it several times
in principle and of course I have to
say sociologist in
principle yes but
social contexts  are very
different and political and
economic and that is exactly
the problem that this lags off ne
so if solutions are then developed
they do not necessarily
also fit the social contexts
if I now think of different parts of
Africa Asia Latin America then
there too  and there too, so to speak,
groups of actors and
so-called users are sometimes said to be picked up in
transdisciplinary research
because they
simply have other
finances and
finances but also have to
act within other legal systems
and so on and that makes it too
difficult and underlines how
important it is
science would then have to be produced in a joint
exchange, so now, if
you like, with scientists from
Angola, so that the solutions then also
fit in Angola, already
mentioned earlier, so I
think an approach that we
actually saw earlier, whoever was here saw that,
was mentioned a moment ago that
namely, they are the UN decade that is
currently running, so that is
a project launched by the United Nations
that runs from 2021 to 2030 and where it is
exactly about the
scientific quasi-procedures
global for marine research global to
its harmony not harmonize
but it  is actually a huge
exchange to exchange, to
actually create incentives for
people to exchange so that there is a
huge potential globally and through this
decade, I think this huge potential is
now really being attacked
and my perception is also a
bit involved in this
decade that is  also really happens
i mean it's not a shelf and it
has to grow first that's exactly so i
think that's a great approach the UN
decade i also have a lot of
interaction and so on but there are
just a lot of scientific systems
that don't exist that's easy
the problem and that's where we have to go
I'd like to have
time for questions at the end or in between,
and if you have
something that's really burning under your nails
then maybe just don't
jump up and call in directly, but
a hand signal, more microphones,
just a short one  give a signal
then we'll take that up and take
that into the discussion I'd
like to talk about a different approach because we're now thinking about the un-dikade
as a tool for
research funding or attention
to
a specific problem that was used in
Europe last year
This mission-oriented
approach was launched and, um, it's about
formulating clear, simple goals, e.g.
fighting cancer or adapting to
climate change, making 150 cities and regions climate
-neutral by 2030 or just
rehabilitating the European seas and waters by 2030, you'll
notice this  from this miss
of the approach what in your own work
is it, for example, what also
has an influence on citizen science projects where suddenly more attention
is being paid to it and maybe more money that's what
it's all about in the end, yes,
I would say more attention
has been going to this science in recent
years, so in German it is called
citizen science and in Germany
there is a portal science in
dialogue in the Anglican-speaking world
it is Universe a platform that is
a platform where you can see for yourself
what you as a citizen where you can look  you
can participate yourself and you
can also click on our sculptures if you are
interested in animals or
in space research or which programs
are suitable for children and young people
then the plastic pirates come along
and err
advertising break science in dialogue means
that and that’s how it is citizens create
know that  it's really fun
to look at i
it's really cool what is a was a
project did you photograph
latin inscriptions in egypt in the 60s
then send us these
photos it's getting really wild there are
great projects also looking through old family photos
with dolmens because
in the past the stones on the
dolmens were simply slipped and on
the old family photos you can see how
they were in the original version or such
stories or joint
excavations, so we now had a
project in Hamburg Schenefeld where all the
citizens were one square meter deep  in the
garden we dug through the
different layers or something and
the nice thing about the plastic pirates is that
earlier we also had the
discussion who is sitting here in this room
are already people who
are, so to speak, interested in the topic
and that's why they are  here in the room or
did they just stroll past
and with the plastic pirates the
volunteers are just the teachers you have to
say the 1,500 teachers the children
are arrested when the teacher says
I'll take part then the whole
school class is at the river and does the
sampling and then  there are also children
and young people who maybe
come from a distant educational home but who
still come into contact with natural sciences
and get to
know scientific knowledge like me if you read the booklet we
have so many materials for
children and for teachers if you then
work through it then you can  you
really deal with how
research works I also have to
take a sample I even have to
take three samples or nine that's
boring but I need a tool
like that
you get to know the research a
little better it's just
not just once  in the year on the ship
I know the time, but there is
also a lot of time on the computer or because
in the laboratory to evaluate it and so
research should also be made recognizable
and the problem is then
closed again with these results in the
scientific journals  end up
because they are only children or they
are not real monitoring people,
only monitoring people can
do that, no, they cannot do that if
you explain it precisely, then
children and young people can do it too and
we hope they learn that way,
at least that’s ours  program also created
a form of self-efficacy they
take the data from the polluted flow
they also take away the garbage afterwards of course
and they see I've
done a small piece of something and it's worth the fact
that I've done it
and ideally the fourth part is
namely  now you're coming do you
also do a project in front of the supermarket
in the family at school and so
on and so
reach more people and
we're trying to show that we
science works
is great is great but can also
be exhausting is a lot of perseverance over
many years you're just a
piece of the puzzle, but if you
work together and then
click on the website and at the same time there are
happy
children's faces in Slovenia or Portugal or elsewhere who
are standing by the river with their rubbish, then
I'll do it now,
then I'll do it too  It's fun and you
can then talk about it, so
the thought is how about the
type of research,
is there interest in it from the
age group, for example, with which
Ms. Ms. Knickmeier
is researching and and so there
is interest there  we
do, in fact, last Friday I was
at our school around the corner
and since
last year I have been doing a project together with
work fox that is a
polar explorer that probably many
people know and someone who has
really been working for 40 years  traveled the Arctic
and is just such a contemporary witness who
knows who sees that who has
seen it all in the end how
everything is changing there and he does it
incredibly well that he just
visits schools and then simply passes this information on to the classes,
no matter what grade level  Of
course he now radiates my
fascination as a real
polar explorer can talk incredibly well
and can then show beautiful pictures
that are also painful
because you can see a lot of what I
have changed and which will
probably never be like us before
really
will be like that again for the time being and that's media, I
think, but how you
can actually pass on situations where it becomes
clear that that has to be done and that
has so in this case it was like that it
wasn't organized if you
did workshops afterwards, everyone
could somehow formulate what can
we do now what I think
is most relevant for all of us first of all
what can we personally do
that is science is something
that gives us insights and
ways of acting but yes
we can do that and that  in
this case it goes through such a format, but
typically it is also relatively
unique,
maybe an additional one, the
sea is so haptic that you can find it
incredibly good, I also
communicate and he feels together
and he smells and feels and so on
and I think  it's incredibly important
to also pass it on to younger
or older age groups to everyone in
the end but also because they are now
asking about children I have to
say in development research
I think this is primarily to be
compared with the exchange with
other cultures  So smelling this,
feeling the entire haptic that
goes with it, being in an African or
Asian context and
talking to little fish there, it’s
not that easy to organize it for the
German school classes,
but
taking children with you
also works quite well  well
i thought so too, so when i talked about your
plastic project that
basically it is one of the really
outstanding examples of where you
have to act globally so it is very
important that this or that is always a
part it is like when i
drive around  and don't throw my Coke can
out of the car that's what I do
of course a Coke can is nothing but
who nobody does that because we all
somehow feel better about it is not
to do that looks great no so
outside and that's kind of a
similar one you could
build up a similar construct from it, that you
create a common identity from it through such problems, that
's really our colleague from Chile,
Professor Martin Thiel, whom I have, he has
the vision that he always
wants to teach the children in Chile, we can
try the cleanest one
To have beaches all over the world or in South America
and he now has a project along the
entire Pacific coast with 13
countries, which is also great
That's why I'm always so sorry when
the children and adolescents and young
people leave climate lectures or something like that with their heads bowed.
I always think it's
very important that there is still hope
and you have a big comrade-in-arms
with you at the GEOMAR Professor Martin
speakers  he was there or he
really keeps an eye on it and
always says and there has to be hope and
I think that's also something very important,
which you can also see with your results.
I'm Anna Massi and I'm
a science communicator and I
also follow the same approach  positive as
at least giving a prospect of a
positive ending, which the
scientific data often does
not promise, or statements based on the
data alone and now I wanted to ask
what an approach can be with the hope that was
actually addressed to us a bit
you say there is
perhaps an overarching possibility for many for
many topics,
how you can encourage children
or how you can not only encourage children, but also
adults, there are also many
depressed people who say what are
we supposed to do here anyway, we are them anyway
last generation they have an
approach to communication
so with us then there will definitely be
something coming from the expert we call that
promoting self-efficacy in
children and young people if you
feel powerless then you don’t do anything
then there is also this castle windows
theory that  when the window
is already smashed then I smash the
others as well if you
convey to the children and young people, so to speak,
that doing something is worthwhile,
I personally think that is very
important and we actually try to do that
with everything we do in  of the
research workshop
because otherwise you can
stop right away yes but yes I
think I am coming from
a different direction now but the ocean
was after the Second World War
it was a source of hope and donor
and I think it is important to be there
to remind again and again that
in the early 1950s at the end of the
1940s on uneven over such people
as the daughter of Thomas Mann
Elisabeth mondogese and others the
world more than one this one
body of water that connects us all
worldwide connects to the center  was asked
to say and let's take that
now and basically use it
as a peace policy measure
that we can mutually agree on we
have this as a sociologist
I would say borderline object yes what
lies between all of us and
enables us very specifically on the basis of this
borderline object  to think about how
we actually want to think about the future, about the
use and
consumption of resources, about how we treat our
planet and ultimately about
ourselves, no, that’s what
happened to you, too, no,
when you hear something like there’s a
plastic carpet in the sea  is as big as a
continent what should you say then
because the question is not a
final answer either but I would like to finish briefly
explaining this
approach to peace policy in relation to the
world ocean that also resonates
in this unocean decade and I
I think it is important to
celebrate and promote again and again. In
the end, we as part of this
cisco project of one of our projects,
we are trying to develop an open ocean silence concept together with the German
UNESCO Commission and others,
so
we now have very
different ones  Artists on
different continents and
communicated and tried to bring
marine sciences and artists
together to reflect on how
the sea is actually artistically
processed in different
cultural contexts and what
conclusions can be drawn about communication with the
sea but also about data management,
more so to speak, everything is still in
development  That's not the
answer that convinces everyone either, but I
believe that the approach is more than a
border object and a peace-political
peace-political object, which
enables us to keep doors of cooperation open
and spaces for dialogue open,
despite the current situation in which
we all feel they are closing
The global
cooperation and dialogue forums are closing everywhere, which
I think is very, very important, and
the UN is definitely supporting the decade to
be a question again, one of
you said we also need something
like visions, a vision at
European level  is formulated is
precisely this we want to rehabilitate our trade fair
several and bodies of water by 2030
and bring them into good condition
how important are such very globally
formulated goals that you
can then use for
research actually from your
experience
yes that’s them  the goals are
okay, i don’t know exactly how this question comes about, the goals are
of course,
they are ultimately always the
same goals if you just
set them as high as possible, no, we
can say that there is a
problem with the oceans  Ocean's
climate and operational
activities, whatever that is,
fishing, otherwise
you can group it all down there, of course,
and then you can
also do it from the global
level to the countries to the
multinational ones, so what the European
level and then to  Breaking the country level down to
the national level again makes
or has to
make a contribution so that the
overall problems
can be tackled or solved and I believe
that I can understand that
with the negative vibes that are
often present in all these things  it's a
fact but that we can't get
out of here now we're here we have to
make the best of it, so to speak, but
that's actually how it is, I
think I think we can make the best of
it the train hasn't
left or anything but the one that is
easily deflectable and salvageable by us
and I think that's a
positive representation that you can also or that
you can
represent positively so that
anyone who is in fourth grade today does
n't have to be frustrated any
more than someone who is now
20 or so  So that can be corrected
or we just have to do something, of course, so
maybe a quick answer to your question,
this target agreement, they are
extremely important, just like the
sustainable development goals are
incredibly important because they simply
make it possible for the
conflict to definitely come up at the moment,
yes, it  It's all about
negotiating conflicts of interest and
that's necessary in order to
advance transformation processes
and that you can always say yes at that moment,
because dear people,
wait a minute, we had agreed on
the goal here on the target and now
we all have to find a way somehow
giving away a bit of
our steaks and interests and so on
in order to move forward together, so
from you, therefore, this agreement on
target values ​​at a high political level,
but also in the mission approach, because you
had previously asked to ask questions,
I think it's not just me that's
personally important, but
Conflict research is also telling us that very clearly
now in relation to your question Hello okay yes thank you
my name and the question camera
also has a bit of who we are here
and I have to explain a little bit
before the question can come
protection of the several bodies of water for me
is something that is very urgent so it does
n't have so many years and so
much time and so much thinking and so
many
small little things
that I had thought about okay
not from this coming from this topic
how can I find out
what can I do  there is also a
bit of public relations
involved I had a bit of time
last year I took two courses online
one from the university in
South Africa that was on the subject of large
marine ecosystems management and
assessment and I have a
question about that and the second  would also be because from
the University of Geneva from the course
that was called
management and policy and uh in
both courses the
system was clearly presented, also by
the World Bank which is actually highly financed
this
global environment facilityf and uh
the whole  The world was also divided into 66
different ecosystems, so to speak,
then quite a
lot of work was also done in the
assessment to see what happened, how do
the different aspects
interact, why
why are there so many problems and of
course it was also looked at regionally
and not just globally but  of course
also specifically looked at the individual
problems
in detail and then
of course it was looked at okay which actors
are there in this region
government actors and etc. so there seemed
to be a system somewhere what is there what
is there for that there is this hub
then um on the  there is also a lot of
information on it, but a lot of it is very
outdated what I could see
and what I then thought about, okay
for Europe, especially the Mediterranean etc. or on
the North Sea, there is also little
information in it that is up to date and
then you can also sort by
e.g. coral reefs  and health of
brain handles quite a lot of links are
outdated but the platform is there it is
there now of course I ask myself
are the political interests
no longer
divergent where one says very clearly
okay it is now the World Bank which
maybe helped build the EU
Then think a bit differently or I do
n't quite understand why I
use what's there and that there is
n't a matrix, for example for
all projects to protect the seas and
waters that exist in the region and
then see okay which functions work and
which functions don't  more for what
reason not what is how much is
invested in I'm only coming to the current
area there is also a financial
tracking service there is
a kind of
database but an instrument where there is
one but the problem is why
why isn't it  more used
and also the lobbying I think that
is of course a very big thing also
for Germany that we just ask
one question first and then
we continue so why why is
it not used why is it so
outdated that is what your
spontaneous experience is  so now
to go specifically to the European dimension,
unfortunately, this is not the right
website, I would say there is
actually how long it
has existed, ten years or something, that is
always the framework,
I only know the English MSF, the
framework cost framework
protection guideline
or yes, the one that we are approaching together
like this,
actually, that is a
directive from the EU, that means every
country has to follow this directive and there
are any number of them and that is also
done, that is done very, very well
I would say and there are  very, very
much information about what is organized in an
organization
but
I would say the problem here is to
carry out research that is so
diverse and especially when you
go to the global level then it is
so
fragmented that you really
have problems  easy to find the right one
and then they
came up with the one time that
was certainly very well entertained for my time but that might
end at some point can also
be for personal reasons but that is
of course a problem if you are
looking for it and you are clear
on the subject  Language is
also an issue, so I used to be
on a Russian
Northeast Passage, the Russians could
all read our things because they
could read English, but none of us could
read Russian and I think that’s the way
we have it with many things  I
said we have to translate our materials into
the languages ​​of the children's countries,
otherwise it wo
n't work you can't say everyone has English, they
understand that, no, it's not like that
and I imagine that even with
this research you're probably
always like that in your cloud  or stays in your
echo chamber
and if you then now that was
probably in English
or French
yes, but those are also problems you
have, so staying in your
echo chamber is a good point that
these power questions have addressed
in it but
I think it hangs there  there is also a
structural dimension behind it and that
is the dimension of
project financing, so the
science is and also the
science that is financed from the development context, so to speak, and there is
a strong implementation component
even with
Jeff’s last system that is always project-financed
and therefore  So it will expire at
some point, then this
website and the portal will no longer be
maintained, others will be set up, no,
and there is basically no
yes, so at a multilateral level there is no
coordinating institution that says yes more in
certain,
for example, mission-oriented
scientific areas
You have to think about climate how you cluster it.
Let's summarize the state of science,
so to speak, the state of knowledge
of mankind from very
different language contexts and
thus also different
scientific systems and then
also see how, for example, in what a
scientific dispute that is
a positive and constructive
scientific dispute then, for
example, analyzes from yes a
Chinese a Russian
North American science system are
related to each other that does not mean that the
science systems
are defined purely nationally or linguistically but they
are very strongly influenced by the
national context simply because of the
funding no and that  this is
a very clear example of this and I
think this digital twins
project, which you mentioned, is
also very closely related to
the actual search for
long-term financing for now, for example,
CO2 marine co2 measurements, so there
is always this balancing of uncertain project financing  for
some areas of science this is
of course a generated competition that also
develops an innovative force and also
ensures efficiency and so
on, but of course that tips somewhere
and also has its limits and there
are certain planetary
challenges that we are clearly in
the limits of the science system
in project funding
one short question that
perhaps goes well with your
experience when you talk about competition
and planetary problems and
the sharing of data and
information and you said there are
more and more attempts between oceans
data platforms and many portals that
I probably don't know about
open source
research and so on but I know there
is also a lot of pressure in science to
get funding you have to
publish you had to publish so many
papers to keep your position
or in science
how are your experiences
and does the social decade somehow contribute to the fact
that you notice there is
a world more or how can you
balance this pressure from
science and competition and the
funds with the
because that we actually
have to share the data  in order to make progress
because luckily
it has actually gained a great deal of focus,
so today you can
no longer
get a project funded if you don't
publish Open Access and it is
actually checked whether you do it
or even if you use the data and if
you  not exactly the one that presents the data plan, so to speak,
that is within
there also within the USA, but
there are also very
many examples of other
countries where this is not the case, that
when we are talking about certain data, for
example fisheries  Data because the
whole thing is much more
complicated again, so it actually depends
on this data in the end, but I
can personally say that
I see it as a very, very big move in
this direction, which, of course,
like everything else, still
has to be developed further  Yes, our publications
are also in Open Access, you have to
remember that you are planning money for one, which means
that some countries cannot
afford to take 4000 euros for a
scientific publication,
yes, one of those costs now
we almost have it  Paid 5000 madness
and those are things too,
but the data itself is on the
website, so you can click on it
and you can find it in our case
now with you, you also share the data
worldwide from the Argo flows from
them  yes, so data in general
is a huge topic because of course
if you say and they are on
a website then I would say
more data-savvy think
nice if someone finds this website
that's just a huge topic how do
I do data that's what you always call it  Machines
to machine readable, that means they are
somewhere and no one should
really look for them by hand by going to
any website but in the
data there are actually formats that
are knitted in the way
that we at Google know that
namely  everything possible in this world
through H vestet to see where we can
get information. There is also something like that
for data, so they can actually
look through where can I find nitrate
as a data record if all possible
data centers are searched and they are
then linked and then you can do it no matter where
I go there now I still get
data from all sorts of other
data centers there are one of these yes
well that is a huge
moment at the moment where a lot has been
done yes there are also a
lot of initiatives in Germany nfdi for
Earth this is a huge project
ultimately where  this whole world of
scientific data together nfdi
in general is such a catchphrase
for the fact that in Germany you
really want to bring all the data together
and make it findable
so exactly I can only confirm
what my colleagues have already
said but there is this open
science movement and
He has just submitted
a corresponding
statement to the Helmholtz Association and
a lot is happening there and at the same time it is of course the
case that it is said in relation to fisheries
where it becomes economically relevant
and interesting, we
as people very consciously have a regime
established what exactly prevents this free flow
of knowledge namely an
intellect for property rights regime which
ensures that certain regions
have access to vaccines for the time being and
others don't for the time being yes and I mean
that from that on the one hand there are
very, very important ones  Processes
in science to enable open science,
but it requires incredibly
strong political will to think about it intelligently
and that's not
as if these regimes that we have built up
intellect for property rights and
so on
are unfounded, so there are
also  good reasons why they
were established to enable
certain companies to invest massively in the first place,
for example to develop the material
and find a balance there
and then, so to speak, what is made
publicly available is also
linguistically accessible  to make it
a huge challenge and also to make it
digitally accessible so it's
not like everyone
on earth has a laptop around the corner
with an internet connection and so on that
's a question
yes I had a
question or at the same time
it's a  A bit of a statement, and
I think it's ours that here at
our universities there is so much
English orientation
I'm interested in
taking part in geology lectures but
roughly I understand that but I can
no longer join the discussion and yes, it doesn't matter
here in the Berlin area or  Potsdam
I know where I hang around almost
always in English and that
the
scientists from Germany are also
obliged to publish in English.
I also came across something
I have
translation programs
that work perfectly
if I write it in English  You
can read Americans fluently but
I also know it should be used in geology. The
luminary used to only
write German. Now English. I
tried to translate it with the same program. It
comes out in gibberish.
I no longer understand that as a geologist.
Water means I wonder if
this language English between the
scientists is
they still understand each other at all
that is they
understand each other when
it is correct and you can do that even
if you look back historically
you always see a flow then there was
a time probably only in German or where
there was  there is a time when a lot of French
is actually quite at least
us around here in our orbit
other orbits
use other languages ​​in fact
I believe but I can have great hope I
also believe that the
translation is not only programs there
but will also be  Simultaneous
translation I think of electronic
type which are very very
satisfying so I ca
n't really share their experiences
as I had when I was little I did
n't even have or the second time a
research trip where we always
write weekly reports and I had
people from Italy
England
France Germany and it does
n't matter a lot in any case I have
to
write this weekly report in a variety of languages ​​geologists
also have one but this I had
this program so I
always translated this weekly report to all
possible languages
just once briefly to read it as
Lecturer pass it on again the weeks are
almost never over so I have very,
very high hopes that in
maybe five years we will even be sitting here
and everyone can choose which
language they would like to hear,
I really think that's going to be huge
progress actually  did you
then use the tip directly to further
difficulties
clear
but I mean what you are addressing is
of course a very specific example of
how difficult it is to
have science and society as one and a constant exchange with each other and that in the
international the  increasingly
internationalized science and
at the same time societies that continue to dwell in many,
many different
language contexts,
so not only in the German context
but yes worldwide is a huge
challenge that you are addressing yes
the question was whether the German
scientists understand each other in English  If
you have a question then you are welcome to use the
microphone because otherwise you won’t be able to understand it
in the room
when you
I want to
explain it using an English example what
an experience
I had in Thailand we
went on the boat through the jungle there were two weaknesses myself
and  an Englishman
the Czechs and I stammered
English we understood each other well
the Englishman and each other
that yes also the beauty of the
international encounter and then there
was no question I would say that's
why I would like something that
interests me because we at the  because we
initially talked about communication with the
public we
talked about how to communicate with
students with children and so on, when it comes to
the question of
science communication, the
implicit assumption that you communicate with
the public does not necessarily
come from
back to the public as it radiates into science, I
often don’t think about what I ask
myself, how open and permeable
is research to impulses that
come from society and
how seriously is
all these initiatives actually taken to
hear what they want  the people what are they
interested in and so i can
maybe say something again very briefly
about the civil sciences we
once gave a lecture about the plastic pirates at the
environmental regulatory office in Dessau
one of the
scientists said to us great great what you are
measuring there now and  the children then,
so to speak, everything that is popping up now
comes back at us like a huge wave
and we then have to do
something with all the terrible data
and that’s also a
bit like that in the civil sciences
when everyone is equipped with sensors
CO2 can be measured here and there everywhere
and here again a small
measurement and then it all comes
together and then shows
our sponsors or the
scientists us scientists, so to speak,
here is a huge
oxygen minimum zone and there we have
a lot of plastic and there is the river
totally dirty like in the photo
of the Elbe and the stins if
a lot of people do that now and say they
can, the whole Elbe is
a single cloudy broth from front to back then
you have to act and that's
something you naturally produce  or
action data and that's also
something I want but it's
not easy to deal with the
knowledge your experience when things like this are brought
to you, for example
I would just
look at it again from the perspective of the history of science, so to speak, here and there  is it already the case
that from 2000 in 2000 there was
a
transdisciplinarity conference in Zurich
which is often viewed as a beginning
of this movement to open up science
and to conduct research together with society together with
social actors
and that
only started in the  Farmer, more so in
the Yes, in agriculture, it
really quickly got things
moving, simply because it is also an area
in which, so to speak, the exchange
with social and
practical actors was already alive anyway,
in fisheries it was similar, but in other
disciplines it was also more closely related
is a bit behind
and
we've been observing that for
about ten years,
I think that's a bit generous,
but in the last ten
years there has also been a very strong
opening, I would say at least in the
German science for
doing science together and
much much more also
to pursue transist binary approaches always in the
awareness that only if you also
develop solution approaches together
then these solutions or the
probability that they correspond to the
local practical context
and can also be applied
is higher and in development research
i have now seen that a bit from the
development research perspective,
these processes are
now firmly anchored because it is
quite clear that otherwise the approaches to solutions
in the very different
scientific economic
contexts are simply also missing the
actor networks, so
to speak, they are not missing
exist in order to carry them into the
implementation and implementation
and that means that
science needs the input to
jointly develop the solution approaches,
but as part of this exchange process
the infrastructures and networks are also
built up in order to be
able to start the implementation at all and  that was
not the case before, for example
now in the water management context
of Central Asia to give our concrete
example, we have been doing research for a
very long time in the BMBF-funded project
to ask
how we deal with salinization of the
soil, how can we
how can  we ensure that
cotton cultivation is less harmful, so to speak,
for agriculture
itself, for the soil and the
water balance above all, and only after
six years of
research, so to speak, without the involvement of
stakeholders
did it take hold that the
knowledge, so to speak, was in the  Heat has already
developed many possible solutions, but
we don't actually know which
of them potentially really correspond to the
conditions of the farmers,
the conditions of the water managers
and the conditions of those
who create these salt maps and who
then determine what can then be cultivated on the
different soils at
all  we
implemented it accordingly and over the next few
years, together with the relevant
water managers and farmers,
further developed the possible possible approaches,
some sorted out quite a lot of them,
I don’t know,
we then worked in a local
context, so to speak, but there were also a few
left over and at the same time as
Part of that was then, but it was also
possible to ensure that certain
changes in the law could also be prepared, so to speak,
in order to be
able to take up that at all. That
is a very regulated
agricultural system in Uzbekistan
for the type of research they do,
what kind of  Input so with
Euros you, for example, to what extent is
there then you can then react to input from
outside at all and what kind of
form does it have to be in so that you
can incorporate it,
so the topic is very very interesting
because research can also
be something that  really
where you just gain knowledge,
so where it is no longer a question of
applying this knowledge in any way applied research
is then the step that was also
written there, I think it often
happened that actually happened so that you
first carry out basic research
around  then from a certain point where
you really have progressed so far
that you also understand how you
could use it and
that's ultimately what you
do in this UCI, so that you have to do that because there
are segments in the project
itself  It's really just about
gaining knowledge or in
basic research to
get a baseline for certain
states and then you can, if you
want to look at changes now, for example, and then carry out management,
then you can probably build on these
management things in
a further phase
so
again I can only say that the
big advantage is that we work with so
many players and the
most diverse levels of
basic research have been achieved,
but also very, very applied methods
how to transfer that directly
from which they are all working  very
different areas what are
slowly to the end what are
from your point of view the biggest gaps
we have the biggest blind
spots um for which we
need more research, for example to achieve the
goal of the EU mission by 2030
i  I see a lot in education,
of course, so promoting young people and
education if we are now
talking about biodiversity, about insects, yes,
you only know whether a species is disappearing
when you know which species
were there at all and to generate these young people
who have this knowledge
that it also a  big topic and a
problem there are also
approaches and programs for this science where you can do it
yourself but you also need the nerds who, so to
speak, the basic researchers
who really go to insect congresses
and talk for hours about certain
species and we do
n’t have them anymore and  I think we
also have a mint problem, ie
mathematics, informatics,
scientific, technical,
young people, we also follow that a
bit with our
school activities and I think
there really is a big
gap that
needs to be filled somehow better,
precisely with communication, but how
If science communication works,
it just works that way, you have to
research it, there are more of them now,
yes,
blind spots in marine research
in marine research, yes, there is
a gap that exists even
if it is tackled with projects like UC and so
on, but it
always is  to understand this this totality,
so what one actually
understands, between what I am
observing here now and what the
benefit of it is in the end, so there
is actually a huge gap
that we can trace back and we
lack, so to speak, so weigh
how to measure yourself  Information
slips through the path I described earlier and
it often happens that things are completely
underestimated. You think oh here
I have this great
weather forecast here, but you
don’t understand where the weather forecast is, what
is actually behind this
weather forecast and maybe then says
anyone why we still have this
weather forecast why should I
continue to finance this and that
so to create this transparency
in the entire values ​​of this
entire value chain for
observation from the observation to the
products that's a huge gap that
we don't have that and that's why
not being able to come up with a lot of arguments and also
making wrong decisions,
yes, I think it ties in very well, so I'm
not so concerned about
the blind spots thematically or
disciplinaryly, I think we've already
worked out that they can
further interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary interaction
we're
still not that good, no,
we can get even better, we'll get
a little bit better every day, but that's
still room for improvement, but I think
what's also very, very central is important
and that's what's guiding us now  the
current, um, geopolitical situation
is again in mind that we also
have to deal with how we work together in education and in science itself, politically
speaking, so there are also
marine science in
climate science in the
Environmental sciences in
sustainability research there
are also
tendencies to
approach the subject areas in a somewhat apolitical way in order to do
research first and of course that also has
its high added value and
at the same time we know we
actually have to deal with how
we promote democratic practices
and thus ourselves as well
socializing again and again we
are in a situation in which 70
percent of the world population now
lives in autocracies these are the
latest figures from the ferrities of on the
macracy index and we are observing these
social
polarization processes which go hand in hand with
political autocratization
in all regions of the world and in all types of
society  and in all
income groups in all countries and that has been going on
for years and that is and is going hand
in hand with a crisis in the
multilateral system, so that we are
becoming less and less able to control and act as a global society, so
I would very much like to see
a mission-related orientation in addition to
one  explicit
reflection on what political
science actually means is
demanded by the Union
and we can see that
the needs are huge now
the climate conference will start in Egypt in a few days
we have
talked about the incredible importance
that this has for both  climate as well as
for the university, what I take with me is
the very encouraging
perspective and the privilege of
living in such a place where research
plays such a big role, where a lot of money
is invested where, um, where people
have perspectives if they
go into the scientific system where we
try to solve questions based on evidence
and yes, even if the problems
are big, I believe what you
said at the end, this
thinking about ecological crises together
with political crises, that you
can’t separate things from each other,
so that  we
need this holistic view of problems
what I have also learned is that there are
data harvesters for
nitrate data, e.g. um that we need more of it
the language is a huge a
big problem so language
among each other within science
that science has this political
dimension of it  who is even allowed to have a
say who is asked what my opinion
is heard erm yeah and we
talked about hope at all and there is
this one nice quote from Karl Popper
optimism is a must you have to
take care of the things that you
have an influence on and that are done
and I think it's kind of
really nice because it's kind of
this insanely big problem what can
I do and I've been
so beaten up if you say it I'm so overwhelmed and I have to
carry all the world's problems on my own shoulders that
takes it  I always get a bit tired of it, that's
why
we take care of the things that we
have an influence on that have to be done
and then we're already a bit further,
so thank you all for
being there, thank you to the BMBF as an
event very good
as organizers of the EFA future talks
and all the people who worked behind the
scenes to make this possible,
come home safely and
have fun at burning street